hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to then this is the official
title burrito Galaxy 64 mega tortilla
bean saga 30 X 6 planetoid SI l5 a 14
xiv director's cut extreme edition now I
was playing this game for a bit and I
thought at first there wasn't a lot to
it but it's actually quite fun I'm gonna
show you what I'm talking about here
this is burrito galaxy's 64 X extreme
edition it's a this is just an early
demo that setup Costa for the green
light for the official game but it's
kind of retro feel to it and that it's
like sort of turn-based and kind of Bing
but you just saw the corner of my the
most horrific enemy that you could
possibly imagine
a burrito burrito but yeah basically you
just kind of fall through the floor and
fight off the enemy hordes of burritos
and spaceship burritos and I don't know
I but I made it quite far before so I
might try to make it even farther oh and
did I mention you need to eat burritos
for sustenance and also kill them and it
controls our arrows and zxc to move
around a burrito
give me that fast bitch-slap the burrito
back until you get your burrito out and
then eat it
O'Kelly oh yeah and also the floor
collapses and you fall down is this game
weird enough for you no got it
Edie yeah you've never been so excited
to eat crappy burritos in your life
maybe you just ate too many bad burritos
and this is some weird drug trip
come on big open area hey I don't know
if the levels are randomly generated but
it would kind of make sense if they were
because I don't think I've seen anything
that's the same ah come on I had that
burrito
I'll tell they do good out here Gary
with a weird Springs froggy Feeny
Wheaties nope alright also I don't know
what I was mentioning it's a breeze ito
Reese it's discreet oh haha now oh crap
but I can defend which means that they
can't hurt me I want my damn burrito you
give me back every house no damn it
you're a burrito you need burritos to
get your house back but you can
technically go indefinitely if you get
enough buried out there going for baby
going for it slap it's like a slight
delay on the actions you hold it down in
another big urban area
yeah it's literally if you look above
kind of unlimited floors
come on floor 15 yeah 15 right now
give me there oh hey look up a bomb I
got two these before you slap them and
they splode that one done I'm trapped
Oh what can you do now you stay away
from me brittle gun dangest damn it ahh
cactus burritos kak Fritos [ __ ] creep
toes I don't know I'm very hungry all
we've done is this game making anyone
else Brad the controls are a little bit
funky by the way it's kind of hard to
turn again with the retro and you only
get 10 seconds per floor oh here we go
a bomb BAM suck on that
I need more burritos in all honesty who
doesn't need more birth ah stop telling
me they hit really hard the farther down
you go so you can't afford to be hit
where are my damn burritos I used to get
like lots of burritos now I get like no
burritos ah
uber ass give me both ah yeah baby
you can ask copies of my burritos the
bombs are pretty good especially if you
get them all grouped up there isn't like
a bonus thing or a bonus soda
kind of like what soda drinkers wrote to
turn themselves into if they could
combine the two with mountain Hill very
blast or whatever I cannot buy anyone
no come on move it's like you gotta hold
it down for some things but not for
turning it's very weird I don't get it
all snow bombs will sometimes blow up
good come on turn move in her the
turning is so wonky the moving is so oh
god oh god oh god I've got blown up and
I get oh it blows up the burritos do I
did not know that
oh no oh yeah actually I'm okay I just
hold here they can't hurt me with my
weird slappy half burrito but that's a
lot of enemies get to the bom bom bom
bom bom bom bom leo
don't block off the bomb only the bomb
will fall in it wolf come on no I'm
still boned oh come on
nope yeah do your little mama
dance somewhere else get the bastards I
don't even know if you are burritos
there whatever the hell you are
oh come on keep getting trapped with no
burritos what a horrible existed
ah you blew up and laugh at the burrito
uh mom I don't know why there's such a
delay sometime oh okay
what is a TT TT plus zero me I have no
idea
Oh big arena kill you guys were there
just a lot more of you and it just out
happen sometimes like I think the
enemies just continue ah come on
yeah fight you know I can't die now come
so far
mom come on
there we go suck on that [ __ ] no second
three house left I'm gonna die fish I
can't believe that I thought oh no oh
God oh come on it's right there oh god
oh god one more hit I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead don't die
don't die come on
well that's the new record for me as you
can see
breno Galaxy 64 Megan Supriya beans
dagoth ur t x6 planetoid sa l5 a xiv
director's cut extreme edition very
interesting if you saw if you look at
the trailer for this game and as opposed
to this this is just a demo the trailer
for this game actually has like
adventure levels and different worlds
and all sorts of stuffin and all kinds
of different burritos that you can enjoy
for yourself so this isn't all there is
but it's pretty darn cool huh so I give
this a try the link is in the
description if you want to play it if
you can beat you can get more than 40
floors write in the comments below so
thank you all so much for watching
forgive you did I've done that's all